I'm sure you've all heard that Steve
Jobs died of pancreatic cancer but maybe
he didn't have to or at least he could
have delayed his death by ears if not
decades you see it while Steve Jobs did
have pancreatic cancer there was a
silver lining in that he had a special
form of pancreatic cancer caused by
islet cells regular pancreatic cancer
only has a five-year survival rate of
1.8 percent but isolated cell tumors
have a fibrous survival rate of up to 93
percent something that's one of the odds
even more in jobs favor was that he
found a cancer extremely early so if
jobs took quick action he could have
very well extended his lifespan by a
substantial amount but instead he
decided to wait 9 months by which point
the cancer had already spread to his
liver